my impression of battlefield 4 is that
they should have had one more meeting on
almost all their ideas nothing
exemplifies that more than the siege of
Shanghai map you know the one they
showed off first at e3 meeting one a
skyscraper falls down meeting two should
have been let's make some kickass rubble
or a sub-basement let's make the tower
into a ramp let's make people fight
through the downtown side ways let's
make the tower fall in an unpredictable
direction I don't know just anything
it's odd but it feels like dice is
finally having those second meetings and
they're using their community test
environment to host and workshop them
that's pretty cool the community test
environment our servers were dice test
new maps ideas and game balance tweaks
in progress open to anyone who owns
premium I can only speculate why they're
still doing it research for battlefield
5 working on mechanics for an alluded to
next DLC of remade fan favorite maps or
a sense that battlefield 4 is still a
work in progress but I'm surprisingly
into it well at least until hardline
launches next month either way star wars
battlefront is indices hands and slated
for a winter release so I want to know
that good ideas are flowing around the
studio's various offices so what's good
about infiltration of Shanghai well
first off it feels like a more
purpose-built map the modis conquest
assault 3d spotting is off flags have
been moved and rooftops locked out maps
that are built for modes like this end
up being way better than watered-down
maps built for multiple nodes Shanghai
on rush my sadness is directed at you
the change is done Shanghai make the map
into a really tense situation with
players doing the cat and mouse or maybe
more accurately cat and cat thing around
objectives there's nothing like rounding
a corner and being unsure if a shadow as
a player or a trash can and that's when
gear suddenly becomes useful the irnv
and floor scopes have huge impact on
this map and mode thermal for tanks and
lav suddenly outweigh the zoom lens
which is a daytime must players
frantically ditch their laser sights
which emit light and give away their
positions totally useless flares
suddenly blind in meaningful ways and
give off an eerie ambient glow street
lights can be shot out and there's
nothing like only realizing a tank is
down the street when tracer rounds begin
splashing off friendly armor next to you
now I know that we've seen this before
battlefield 3 star on highway
in bad company choose nelson bay oh crap
we have seen this before well keep it up
dice it's a step back in the right
direction of making maps more distinct
and meaningful for the Battlefield
franchise